my name is Caitlin Britannic and I'm
here and healthy which is like a really
big deal I tested positive for the brca1
genetic mutation which means that I have
a very high risk of developing breast
cancer in my lifetime I got tested at 25
because he's the only surviving person
in his family they've all died of cancer
both parents and both sisters I was
about to lose my insurance so I was like
okay fine I'll go get tested and I went
in to see if I had a gluten allergy and
they were like no you should really get
tested to see if you have like this
breast cancer gene as they call it and
so I was I tested positive for brca1
when you are high-risk when you're BRCA
your medical folder gets red tagged and
you kind of go to go to the head of the
class so that meant that not only did I
have a mammogram when I was younger than
the average woman but I had this MRI
where they put a contrast dye in you and
then once the dyes in your body you do
an MRI and then they can check and see
if anything's off then you have to wait
for like other information and that
whole process of like sitting in a
hospital waiting for an MRI having all
of it just like really freaked me out
and I just didn't want to be in that
center I didn't want to be next to
cancer patients because I felt horrible
I felt guilty that I was taking time
away from them so I just ran away from
it completely the whole thing I was like
okay I'm not getting surveillance I hate
my breasts and they're really affecting
my body my self-esteem and I'm pretty
miserable and at the time doctors were
just suggesting that women if they
choose to have a mastectomy preventative
ly it's after they're finished
breastfeeding once they're like into
menopause so I told my family and they
were all really shocked but as I
explained it and explained how I didn't
feel authentic in my body I felt like I
was hiding I was not going to the doctor
it made a lot more sense to everyone to
have the surgery basically what they do
is they remove all of the breast tissue
because all of those cells have a high
risk of becoming cancerous
and for that they remove all of the
breast tissue but they don't go into the
chest wall your PEC muscle stays intact
you can choose to rebuild or not to
rebuild and I did not know what to
choose so for me I wanted to go really
gradually because I could not choose
like I had no concept I knew I wanted
small breasts smaller breasts but like I
was sick of looking like a Russian
nesting doll I wanted to look like a
Russian ballerina I think I just wanted
to feel like this light and easy and
like fun but I also had no idea what I
was doing and I actually had to convince
a couple doctors that this was the right
decision for me there was giving me a
lot of anxiety with my now husband
doctors told me that I had like a less
than 1% chance after I had my surgery
and I think he could change based on
women keep their nipples or not keep
their nipples but they told me less than
1% which was great but I still have a
risk of ovarian cancer and with this
mutation I have an elevated risk of
pancreatic cancer and melanoma that was
something that was a little difficult to
handle in the beginning because when you
think of having a preventative double
mastectomy you hear that and it feels
like it's a one-time deal just you know
like you have knee surgery or you'd have
you know a replacement the thing with
this type of surgery is because they are
removing body parts and adding new
implants and your body's changing
it takes a lot longer than you'd realize
so going through the second surgery was
really confusing to me in a way because
I had no idea what it would be like but
I still had this really recent memory of
how it felt right as soon as I woke up
from surgery or how it hurt to move my
arm at first and so my doctor said it
was really common that you'd have these
fears that were sort of these fresh
feeling fears but at the same time you
don't actually know how you'll feel so
it's this like bizarre premature
nervousness and so that surgery happened
and it was a lot easier than my first
surgery because in the mastectomy
surgery when they remove everything your
full chest like just feels like it's
been
ripped apart which is like it sounds
disgusting but you're fine you're it's
bandaged you're on meds it's okay but
but you're just your body really feels
like it was like assaulted like it
really has to heal and in the second
surgery it's a little less so you know
there's less movement of the muscles
there's less things that have to rebuild
also when you have surgery like this
they when they remove the tissue they
also like sever a bunch of nerves so you
really don't have any feeling in your
breasts so that was kind of a crazy
thing to no longer have any feeling and
doctors told me that like I couldn't
wear put like a hot compress on for too
long or they said you can't cook over an
open flame because like you might not
feel it also you can't wear underwire
bras because the bra might poke you and
you might not feel it now years later I
can feel pretty well and my nerves have
grown back but in the beginning they
were very very cautious if a friend asks
me like should I get tested do I need to
get tested why I always say like well
you can talk to your doctor they'll
advise you you know it's up to you to
get tested but that's a lot of
information and even though you might
not have cancer that diagnosis feels
sometimes you feel like you have cancer
it's it's around the corner and it's
really hard to shake that and so once
you know it I think it's helpful to know
and you can empower yourself but also
it's good to know like is this
information gonna just destroy me right
now because it just it did for me it was
just too much and it's such a crazy
feeling to have the sentencing in
surgery and now to love my body more
which sounds insane like it sounds crazy
and if somebody said that to me I don't
know if I'd believe them and I don't
know if they were just like on some pink
cloud and just decided you know they
were lying to themselves but I really
feel so much better in my body
and so much calmer and I never think of
breast cancer and I'm just really happy
that like my kids aren't gonna have to
see their mom go through breast cancer
[Music]